is this one:
If Internet is the new printing press,
then what is democracy for the Internet era?
What institutions do we want to build
for the 21st-century society?
I don't have the answer, just in case.
I don't think anyone does.
But I truly believe we can't afford to ignore this question anymore.
So, I'd like to share our experience
and what we've learned so far
and hopefully contribute two cents
to this conversation.
Two years ago, with a group of friends from Argentina,
we started thinking, "how can we get our representatives,
our elected representatives,
to represent us?"
Marshall McLuhan once said that politics
is solving today's problems with yesterday's tools.
So the question that motivated us was,
can we try and solve some of today's problems
with the tools that we use every single day of our lives?
Our first approach was to design and develop
a piece of software called DemocracyOS.
DemocracyOS is an open-source web application
that is designed to become a bridge
between citizens and their elected representatives
to make it easier for us to participate from our everyday lives.
So first of all, you can get informed so every new
project that gets introduced in Congress
gets immediately translated and explained
in plain language on this platform.
But we all know that social change
is not going to come from just knowing
more information,
but from doing something with it.
So better access to information
should lead to a conversation
about what we're going to do next,
and DemocracyOS allows for that.
Because we believe that democracy is
not just a matter of stacking up
preferences, one on top of each other,
but that our healthy and robust public debate
should be, once again, one of its fundamental values.
So DemocracyOS is about persuading and being persuaded.
It's about reaching a consensus
as much as finding a proper way
of channeling our disagreement.
And finally, you can vote
how you would like your elected representative to vote.
And if you do not feel comfortable
voting on a certain issue,
you can always delegate your vote
to someone else, allowing
for a dynamic and emerging social leadership.
It suddenly became very easy for us
to simply compare these results
with how our representatives were
voting in Congress.
But, it also became very evident that
technology was not going to do the trick.
What we needed to do to was to find
actors that were able to
grab this distributed knowledge
in society and use it to make better and more fair decisions.
So we reached out to traditional political parties
and we offered them DemocracyOS.
We said, "Look, here you have a platform that you can use to build
a two-way conversation with your constituencies."
And yes, we failed.
We failed big time.
We were sent to play outside like little kids.
Amongst other things, we were called naive.
And I must be honest: I think, in hindsight, we were.
Because the challenges that we face, they're not
technological, they're cultural.
Political parties were never willing
to change the way they make their decisions.
So it suddenly became a bit obvious
that if we wanted to move forward with this idea,
we needed to do it ourselves.
And so we took quite a leap of faith,
and in August last year, we founded
our own political party,
El Partido de la Red,
or the Net Party, in the city of Buenos Aires.
And taking an even bigger leap of faith,
we ran for elections in October last year
with this idea:
if we want a seat in Congress,
our candidate, our representatives
were always going to vote according to
what citizens decided on DemocracyOS.
Every single project that got introduced
in Congress, we were going vote
according to what citizens decided on an online platform.
It was our way of hacking the political system.
We understood that if we wanted
to become part of the conversation,
to have a seat at the table,
we needed to become valid stakeholders,
and the only way of doing it is to play by the system rules.
But we were hacking it in the sense that
we were radically changing the way a political party
makes its decisions.
For the first time, we were making our decisions
together with those who we were
affecting directly by those decisions.
It was a very, very bold move for a two-month-old party
in the city of Buenos Aires.
But it got attention.
We got 22,000 votes, that's 1.2 percent of the votes,
and we came in second for the local options.
So, even if that wasn't enough to win a
seat in Congress, it was enough
for us to become part of the conversation,
to the extent that next month,
Congress, as an institution, is launching
for the first time in Argentina's history,
a DemocracyOS to discuss,
with the citizens, three pieces of legislation:
two on urban transportation and
one on the use of public space.
Of course, our elected representatives are not
saying, "Yes, we're going to vote
according to what citizens decide,"
but they're willing to try.
They're willing to open up a new space
for citizen engagement and hopefully
they'll be willing to listen as well.
Our political system can be transformed,
and not by subverting it, by destroying it,
but by rewiring it with the tools that
Internet affords us now.
But a real challenge is to find, to design
to create, to empower those connectors
that are able to innovate, to transform
noise and silence into signal
and finally bring our democracies
to the 21st century.
I'm not saying it's easy.
But in our experience, we actually stand a chance
of making it work.
And in my heart, it's most definitely
worth trying.
Thank you.
(Applause)